♪ [music] ♪
So to assess dividend policy for a
company, not only do you have to assess
how much the company could have paid in
dividends, the free cash flow to equity,
you also have to look at
what it actually does return.
You also have to get a measure
of whether your company has good projects
and whether it delivers solid return
to its stockholders.
That is what we did for Disney.
But we can replicate what we did for
Disney for all of the other companies
in our sample. So let's try this on
Vale. Vale is a large Brazilian
mining company, actually,
a global mining company incorporated
in Brazil. Let's look at what it pays out
in dividends and what it could have
paid out. In the period that I looked
at, at Vale, its free cash flows
to equity were actually negative,
minus $1.9 billion if I don't count debt.
And if I do count debt,
it's about $1 billion.
The company managed to return almost
$42.8 billion in the form of dividends
and buybacks. In fact,
even if I use a target debt ratio,
the free cash flow to equity I get is
only $19 billion. It is beyond doubt
that Vale during this time period was
returning way more than it could in the
form of dividends and buybacks than it
could. So, really, the question becomes,
what do we do next? Clearly this is a
problem, right? A company that pays
out vast amount in dividends and
buybacks with cash flows it doesn't have.
So I'm going to try something.
I'm going to be the CEO of Vale,
and I'm going to put you in the role
of a shareholder and I'm going to get
up and ask for a change. A change in what?
A change in my dividend policy.
I'm going to make the case on
those cash flows. I'm going to say,
"Look I can't afford to pay
what I'm paying in dividends,
I just don't have the cash flow."
Sounds reasonable, right?
But let me fill in the rest of the story.
Part of the reason Vale has to pay the
dividends that they do is they have two
classes of shares. We talked about this
at the very start of the class,
voting shares and non-voting shares.
One of the conditions that come with the
non-voting shares that allows them
to be non-voting is Vale's committed
contractually to pay dividends
on those shares. If it fails to pay those
dividends on those preferred shares,
it has to give up voting rights.
So if you're a shareholder, odds are,
you're a non-voting shareholder,
you are the one receiving dividends,
and what's Vale CEO asking,
"Can I pay you less in dividends, right?"
Before you agree, what would you
like in return? Think about it.
You demanded those large dividends because
I told you, you could not vote.
Now, I'm asking you to cut those
dividends. I would assume that you're
going to push back and say,
"You can do that as long as you give me
voting rights." In many companies the
desire for control is so strong that
companies will continue to pay dividends,
a little like Vale does, and drive
themselves into bankruptcy
rather than give up control.
So with the case of Vale,
are they paying out too much in dividends?
Absolutely. Can they do something
about it? Only if they're willing to give
up control. So let's try this on a company
I haven't talked about so far, BP,
large oil company. And, in fact,
this is way back in time between 1982 and
'91. Between 1982 and 1991,
BP reported free cash flows to equity on
average each year of about $571 million
a year. That's a pretty large cash flow,
right? So let me ask you a question,
it's a pretty obvious question.
If you have free cash flows to equity
of $571 million a year,
how much can you afford to pay
in dividends each year?
Good answer is roughly
$571 million, right?
But here's what BP managed to do.
In this 10-year period BP consistently
managed to pay about $1.5 billion
in dividends every year. You see,
how does a company with $571 million
in free cash flow to equity pay $1.5 in
dividends? Each year for this period BP
went out and borrowed $1 billion
every year, not to take projects,
not to drill more wells,
but to pay in dividends.
Clearly, the company has a dysfunctional
dividend policy. It's paying way too much
in dividends. Now, the puzzling question
is, "Hey, why didn't BP do something
about it right away?"
Now, here's the reason.
Companies, once they get into a
dysfunctional dividend policy,
can't back away. As BP started paying
bigger and bigger dividends in the
early 1980s, it started attracting
investors who like those dividends.
So they bought BP stock because they liked
big dividends. For lack of a better word,
these were dividend addicts,
they were addicted to dividends,
and they're now stockholders in your
company. Think of the problem you face.
What are you going to do?
Are you going to go in front of those
stockholders who really love their
dividends and tell them, "Hey look,
we can't afford to pay those dividends?"
You could try, but it's not going to
go well. So BP kept putting off the bad
decision year after year after year hoping
that something good will happen.
Which for an oil company is that oil
prices will go up and perhaps,
perhaps the dividend problem will go away.
That didn't happen. And, in fact,
in 1991 BP was forced to cut dividends.
You know why? Because when they went to
the bank to borrow the billion dollars
to pay the dividends as they had the
previous 10 years, the bank said,"You're
already the most highly levered oil
company in the world,
we're not funding you dividends."
They cut dividends.
Now, we all agree based on a corporate
finance stand point that this is the right
thing to do. The company cannot afford
those dividends. But to show you that the
world doesn't always behave the way
corporate finance textbooks would want
them to behave. When this dividend cut
was announced, the stock price dropped.
In fact, to complete the story,
it fully recovered a few weeks later.
But you're saying, "What happened during
those weeks?" So when the dividend cut
was announced, these dividend addicts sold
their shares, drove the price down.
And it took a few weeks for other
shareholders to step in and fill
the breach. And during that period,
half of BP stock management lost
their jobs. And if you ask me,
they deserved to. They deserved
to for putting off this decision for as
long as they did. My advice to companies
with dysfunctional dividend polices,
policies like BP, is do something about it
quickly while you still control your
destiny. Don't deal with it only
after you're forced to cut dividends.
In fact, changing dividend policy is
always one of the most difficult
things for a company to pull off.
And it goes back to that dividend
clientele effect we talked about,
you get the stockholders we deserve.
So if you are a company that's paying too
much in dividends, a company like BP,
and you're saying, "How do I cut dividends
without having a stock price effect?"
The bad news is you cannot.
Because when you cut dividends,
your stock price will drop.
The question is, can you bundle your
cutting dividends with something that
might make the drop in stock prices less
severe? And there are things you can try,
in fact, there are studies that look at
dividend cuts accompanied by other
new stories. If the dividend cut is
accompanied by just a drop in earnings.
That's the worst possible scenario
because investors say they cut dividends
because times are bad,
and they had no choice.
So you look at the stock price effect,
not only is it large at the day
of the announcement,
it continues for weeks after.
If you cut dividends and you announce with
it simultaneously that you're taking
projects with that cash,
maybe people don't believe you right away,
the stock price does drop on the
announcement day but to the extent that
you can deliver news.
So deliver information that backs up your
argument that there are good investments,
you might see the stock price come back.
Now, don't take any of this
stuff in these studies literally.
It doesn't mean that if you do
exactly this, you're going to get the same
impact. But it's worth thinking about if
you have to announce a change in dividend
policy. You might want to make it a more
comprehensive announcement about why
you're doing it, and what you hope to do
with that cash. Maybe markets will treat
you more fairly if you do that.
Let's move on to a fourth example.
This is again, a company I haven't talked
about so far, it's The Limited.
And in 1992, The Limited was a high-growth
retail company. The reason I picked The
Limited is in the 10 years leading into
1992, The Limited's free cash flow to
equity was minus $34 million a year
on average.
Now, think about it.
If you have negative free cash flow
to equity, and I ask you how much
can you afford to pay in dividends,
the answer is nothing, right?
The Limited managed to pay $41 million
in dividends even though it was a
high-growth company taking good projects.
You're saying, "How come?"
Why would a high-growth company that
requires the money to take
reinvestment start paying in dividend?
So let me lay out the argument that
probably got The Limited started on the
policy of paying dividends.
Early in the 1980s, the free cash flows
to equity were negative.
Let's assume they were visited
by a consultant. The consultant says,
"Look, by not paying in dividends,
you're making yourself a stock
that many shareholders can't buy."
And that's actually true.
There are some pension funds that cannot
invest in shares that
don't pay in dividends.
So here's what the
consultant suggests,
"Why don't you pay a token dividend?" The
Limited's dividend payouts started as a
token dividend with $1 million.
But here's the problem,
when you pay a token dividend they
attract those investors into your stock
who like dividends, guess what they want
the next year? More dividends,
and still more dividends.
And that's the pathway that led The
Limited to where it is today.
So if you're a company that cannot afford
to pay dividends, you have
negative free cash flows to equity,
don't go looking for trouble.
Don't pay a token dividend or a small
dividend hoping that,
that will be sufficient.
Because you're attracting investors who
are, in fact, investors you don't want
buying your shares if you're a young
growth company with negative cash flows.
Let's do one final example.
And this is Tata Motors.
If you look at the free cash flows to
equity for Tata Motors pre-debt,
it is minus ₹106 billion.
Even if you count that up with the target
debt ratio, the free cash flow to
equity is about ₹48 billion.
The reason I emphasized that is no matter
what your measure of free cash flow
to equity, it turns out that what was
returned by Tata Motors during this period
₹75.184 billion exceeds those
free cash flow to equity. In fact,
the only way you can explain the
higher dividends is during this period
Tata Motors went in and increased its debt
ratio significantly by borrowing huge
amounts of money. Remember in our
assessment of capital structure we said
that Tata Motors was over levered.
One reason they have too much debt is
because the acquisitions they did during
the period. The other reason is because
they're paying out dividends that they
can't afford to pay out. Here again,
there might be a reason that explains why
Tata Motors does what it does.
It is part of a family group.
And when you have a family group
of companies, when one company
pays out more than it can afford to,
maybe another company in the
group is making up the difference.
As with capital structure, I think,
Tata Consulting Services,
which is the Tata group's biggest and
most profitable company is, in a sense,
subsidizing the dividend policies of all
of the older Tata companies,
something to think about when you
look at a family group company.
So let's think about bringing this
process to fruition for your company.
You've assessed the potential dividend,
the free cash flow to equity,
you've looked at the actual dividend,
you've looked at what kinds of projects
your company has, you've also looked at
what kind of Jensen's have or returns your
stock has been delivering over time.
You're in a position to make a judgement
about the company's dividend policy.
If your company is holding back cash and
has a history of taking bad projects
and delivering poor returns,
you're well within your rights to ask
for your cash back. If it's burning
through cash by paying out more than it
can afford to, and it has good projects,
I think you have to start thinking about
how do you bring the company back
to worth and get it to pay less in
dividends because it needs that cash
to take the projects.
It is a subjective judgment.
But it's a judgment you have
to make nevertheless.
♪ [music] ♪